[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone
i'm john coogan and this is my analysis
of the cyberpunk 2077 launch fiasco
to be clear this isn't a game review
channel by any means
so i'm going to be focusing on the
business of cyberpunk i've been enjoying
the game for a few weeks now
but i completely understand why people
who bought this game with high
expectations are frustrated
regardless of what you think about the
game there are some important lessons
about launching a product that every
entrepreneur should pay attention to
so that's what i'm going to focus on
today let's start with a little history
cyberpunk is an action rpg created by a
polish company called cd project
the company is the largest video game
maker in poland
but is actually fairly small by american
standards
they are currently worth 8 billion
dollars which is about the same as
discord
they aren't really a startup though
since they've been around since the mid
90s
but because their business involves
launching entirely new games on a
regular basis
each new title they release acts
somewhat like a small startup
cd project has an interesting backstory
the founders started by selling
cracked copies of western video games in
warsaw poland as kids
once they got older and started wanting
to do business legitimately
they focused on importing games from the
united states
as demand for american games grew in
poland they started offering translation
services to american game developers
so that the games could be enjoyed by
polish people who didn't speak english
this business grew with the overall
rising popularity of video games
and it paved the way for them to start
making their own games cd projekt's main
hit has been the witcher franchise
which includes three main games as well
as a few expansions and spin-offs
it's also been adapted into a netflix
original series starring henry cavill
cd project was in the perfect position
to work on the witcher because the
author of the books that the series is
based on
is polish and cd project is a polish
company
the witcher series has been a massive
success earning multiple game of the
year awards
and helping cd projekt go public on the
polish stock exchange
after seeing so much success with the
witcher adaptation
cd projects set out to find new
intellectual property to base their next
game off of
they settled on an old tabletop
role-playing game from the 1980s called
cyberpunk
expectations were immediately sky high
for cyberpunk 2077
and cd projekt did nothing to calm fans
down they brought keanu reeves on to
play one of the main characters
and even had him hype the game to fans
at e3 just look at how he sold the game
cyberpunk
is set in a metropolis of the future
where body modification has become an
obsession
you play as an outlaw an enhanced
mercenary
working in the sleazy underbelly of the
city
okay but let me tell you the feeling
of of being there of walking the streets
of the future
is really going to be breathtaking but
when the game finally launched after
multiple delays
it was riddled with bugs and was nearly
unplayable on current generation
consoles like the ps4 and xbox one
textures were low resolution animations
were buggy
and some problems would even kill your
character instantly
or even crash the game entirely
generally the game was a mess
and fans weren't happy cd projekt's
stock dropped
20 percent after the launch and they
quickly began offering refunds to gamers
who were unhappy with their purchase
many online stores began issuing
warnings to customers about the game's
issues
and sony even went as far as to pull the
game entirely from their online store
my experience with the game has been
generally positive i'm a big fan of the
cyberpunk aesthetic
and i like action rpgs as a genre while
i have experienced a few bugs while
playing
i'm running the game on a custom-built
pc with a high-end graphics card
so most of the issues haven't been a
problem i'm also not the type to binge
play a game the day it comes out
so i've been able to avoid the worst
bugs just by downloading updates
i'm also more forgiving of bugs
generally since i'm an early adopter by
nature
and this isn't the first game by cd
projekt to have issues at launch
when they launched the first witcher
game it was far from perfect
they actually released an enhanced
edition of that game a full year later
which upgraded the graphics and fixed
many bugs
and they pulled off something even more
impressive with the third installment of
the witcher
when the witcher 3 was released in 2015
for pc
ps4 and xbox one it was widely called
one of the best video games ever made
and was praised for its expansive open
world four years later
cd projekt was able to port the game to
the nintendo switch
a portable gaming console with a
fraction of the computing power of the
other platforms
so if anyone can get cyberpunk to
eventually run smoothly on older
hardware
it's cd project but while i don't doubt
that the engineers and game designers at
cd projekt can build a great game
i do have reservations about their
marketing strategy by endlessly hyping
the game
they really damage their reputation in
the gaming community over 8 million
people had pre-ordered the game and they
expected a flawless experience on day
one
if a game company is uncertain about
their ability to deliver a polished
product at launch
they usually release into early access
allowing gamers to play a limited
version of the game
this lets them get tons of real world
feedback and test for bugs across
a much wider range of hardware but
launching into early access
can be humbling for a big company and it
can also be less profitable
often early access games are sold at a
discounted price
and it can be hard to deploy a huge
marketing budget effectively
when the game has already been kind of
available for fans
as we've seen time and time again
there's very little substitute for real
world feedback
video games are the perfect medium for
rapid iteration and that's why most of
the highest grossing games of all time
are services that add features
consistently over time
games like minecraft roblox and fortnite
have all grown in public with real world
players testing new features
as they roll out but these games have
the advantage of not being primarily
narrative driven
the cyberpunk fiasco is so interesting
to me because it has several
deeply ironic aspects to it first
the game's narrative focuses on themes
of inequality and corporate abuse
but the game only runs well on expensive
custom-built pcs
leaving gamers who can't afford the
latest gaming hardware behind
to be fair this isn't entirely cd
project's fault
they began the development of cyberpunk
eight years ago
that's before the release of the
original ps4
development took so long though that by
the time the game was ready
the ps5 was already available and these
two consoles have significantly
different capabilities
the graphics processing unit in the ps5
is almost six times as powerful as the
ps4s
and it has twice as much memory so
making a game that takes advantage of
next-gen hardware like the ps5
will naturally lead to some compromises
on legacy consoles
but i wonder how deeply the team at cd
projekt thought about all this
it seems odd to write a whole story
about the problems of inequality
while releasing a product that will
ultimately leave less wealthy customers
unsatisfied i think they're doing the
right thing by offering refunds to these
customers
but it feels like they should have
delayed the console release entirely
it's not uncommon for games to launch on
one platform and then expand to other
platforms later
like cd projekt did with the nintendo
version of the witcher
doing this pushes revenues further out
into the future though and that has a
real business cost
the second ironic twist here involves a
particular bug some gamers have been
experiencing
in certain situations if the player gets
too many items in their inventory
the file that saves their progress will
be corrupted entirely
forcing them to start the game over from
the beginning
this is ironic because without spoiling
the story
one of the major plot points in the game
involves a kind of ticking time bomb
it's funny that there's a race against
the clock both in the main story of the
game
as well as the real world you have to
finish the game before gathering too
many items
or you might lose your progress and have
to start over
i think the story of the cyberpunk
launch should be instructive to
entrepreneurs who are launching anything
new
it always pays to get your product into
the hands of real users as soon as
possible
we saw quivi make the terrible mistake
of launching blindly without feedback
and it cost them the entire company even
with a few successful launches under
your belt
you aren't exempt from real world
feedback so try to beta test new
products with your most dedicated users
before you announce a specific launch
date early signs point to cyberpunk
still being a profitable game
even with the launch debacle but it's
unclear how much this will hurt cd
projekt's reputation in the future
hopefully they continue improving the
game until it becomes a fan favorite
but only time will tell so have you
played cyberpunk
let me know what you think about the
game in the comments below and if you
enjoyed the video
please consider subscribing to the
channel i don't plan on covering video
games regularly
but when i see an interesting business
case about a game i'll talk about it
so thanks for watching